So here is my solution to the programming
assignment where I asked you to program an
online version of online SLAM. Let me run it
and compare it to the offline SLAM. When
I run it, I get random landmarks and a random
initial robot pose. My offline solution gives me
this long path over here and estimated landmarks,
and the remarkable thing here is that my online
version that I coded gives me the same final pose
and the same landmarks without retaining this huge
matrix for the path before. So how did I do this?
Here is my online SLAM routine. In large parts
it looks exactly like my offline SLAM routine.
I do it in 2D – I have a measurement and motion.
Step, here is my measurement update. I have to
get all these indices right so you can stare at
them for a while, but they’re all correct here,
there is a plus one and minus one over here.
And here is the first nontrivial thing. My
matrix so far has one robot pose and one
entry for each landmark, but now I need to
add space for the next robot pose. And the
way I do this is, I make an expansion list
using the expand command. And this expansion
list retains the original robot pose, which is
coded 0 and 1, these are two-dimensional
poses, and indices for the landmarks.
So, I’m squeezing in two new rows and two new
columns for the next robot pose. That’s
happening in this code over here. With this
squeezed in, I can now do the update. The
update is being applied exactly at these two
new rows and columns that I put in. And here
is the math I gave you for factorization applied
to this problem, where I go and compute the
intermediate matrices A, B and C that I
explained in class. And then I use the take
command to kick out the very first row and
column, the first two of them, to remove the
old robot pose, using the exact same logic
that I gave you in class. So you can look at
this, this actually implements online SLAM.